bonsoir le 78 lactu le journal de la
rédaction merci de nous rejoindre sur
TVfil 78 comme chaque soir en direct à
partir de 18h voici les principaux
titres qui seront développés le pôle
Molière au Murau un ensemble
d'équipement au bénéfice des habitants
école salle de spectacle de sport
logement avec pour mot d'ordre la
maîtrise de l'énergie ce samedi quatre
associations de riverins de l'aérodrome
de saint-ciier l'école manifesteront
contre les nuisances aériennes les
plages de silence qui demande ne sont
toujours pas mises en place nous en
parlerons avec l'une des responsables de
ces associations à la Coupe de France de
l'Américaine une compétition de cyclisme
sur piste visuellement impressionnante
entre vitesse et passage de relais ce
sera en fin de journal cette
organisation réunit ensemble donc sur
une journée d'action contre la politique
d'austérité du gouvernement l'image du
jour ce sont donc ces manifestants
mobilisés pour l'emploi public et les
salaires les fonctionnaires à nouveau
dans la rue à l'appel de SEP syndicat
des rassemblements se sont déroulés dans
la plupart des départements dont les
Yvelines comme ici à Versailles ils
étaient une centaine l'annonce par le
gouvernement du maintien du gel du point
d'indice jusqu'en 2017 pour les
fonctionnaires à mis le feu au poudre on
écoute l'un de ces fonctionnaires en
colère au micro de Jérémy
ebras il y a des augmentations pour
certains de temps en temps mais que pour
les haut cadres c'estàdire que je vais
prendre l'exemplei dans la police un
commissaire de police peut toucher une
prime de 50000 € et on nous dit qu'il y
a pas d'argent pour payer des papiers
des crayons ou même embaucher des gens
je DIRIS ave que cel on peut embaucher
au moins deux trois personnels voire
même un commissaire on aimerait bien pas
manifester juste avoir notre juste d on
demande pas plus on demande juste que
nos droits soient respectés une ville
qui change de visage au Mureau la
rénovation urbaine passe par la
réalisation d'un quartier de haute
qualité écologique production
d'électricité récupération de l'eau pour
les écoles les salles de spectacles
encore de sport et les logements visite
explication avec Olivier Man et Jonathan
Vman une rénovation urbaine de haute
qualité environnementale c'est au Murau
sur 70 hectares et 6 quartiers que
s'opère un vaste chantier depuis
septembre 2012 crèche école maternelle
et primair centre de loisir et ludotch
le pôle Molière proposera dès la rentrée
prochaine ses multiples activités tout
en s'intégrant parfaitement à
l'environnement ce qui est important
dans ce bâtiment ça a été toute la
question énergétique et le développement
donc il y a eu tout un travail à la fois
sur la construction des bâtiments donc
sur le traitement des façades avec des
systèmes de disolation par l'extérieur
on a créé des boîtes isolées hein si on
peut se permettre donc qui consomment le
moins possible mais qui sont également
les plus lumineuses on passe sur des
bâtiments qui consomment donc très peu
on est sur des consommations de
chauffage qui sont inférieurs à 15 kW
par mètre Carr et par an les bâtiments
passifs deviennent même positifs grâce à
l'action des 450 m carré de panneaux
photovoltaïques placés sur les toits le
pôle moliiaire produit donc plus
d'électricité qu'il n en consomme et
pourra réinjecter l'énergie dans le
réseau public les eaux pluviales sont
également récupérées et filtrées via des
nous creusés dans la rue et le long des
bâtiments des aménagements écologiques
qui ont coûté plus cher qu'un projet
classique mais qui au fil du temps
s'avéreront rentable l'investissement
confess sur un bâtiment doit se compter
sur le long terme donc là effectivement
l'investissement sur le long terme vu
les économie d'énergie qu'on va faire
euh voilà vu de ce point de vue-là le
bâtiment n'est pas plus coûteux ce qui
est coûteux aujourd'hui c'est
l'entretien des bâtiments du 19e siècle
c'est le grand débat que faire de ces
vestiges du 19e siècle qui sont certes
beau et très très très bien à l'usage
mais qui d'un point de vue
énergétique totalement décalé par
rapport à notre époque 17 millions
d'euros ont été nécessaires pour
financer les travaux du pôle Molière
l'oréa 2012 du Prix bâtiment positif
décerné par laadème les 6000 m Carr du
complexe seront livrés à la fin de cet
été
l'invité du journal à présent bonsoir
Muriel gu vous êtes la présidente de
l'association contre les nuisances
sonores à noisileri et à Bahi également
il y aura de l'animation à l'aérodrome
de saint-s l'école samedi matin des 9h
puisque vous appelez avec trois autres
associations de Riverin à manifester
vous dénoncez notamment l'augmentation
du trafic aérien ces dernières années et
donc les hausses des nuisances c'est
bien ça quelles sont vos difficultés au
quotidien exactement en fait aujourd'hui
nous sommes quatre associations de
Riverin qui représentent les hab de H
communes autour de la plaine de
Versailles et nous appelons à manifester
contre les dangers et les nuisances
sonores de l'activité aérienne de
l'aérodrome de sainir l'école
concrètement quelles sont les les
difficultés que vous rencontrez quelles
sont les les nuisances au quotidien vous
pouvez pas ouvrir les fenêtres alors
nous pouvons ouvrir nos fenêtres en fait
il se trouve que cette plateforme est
dans une zone urbanisée de 100000
habitants et il y a vraiment que deux
trajectoires qui n'offrent aucune
possibilité de sortie et d'entrée hors
survol d'habitation donc nous sommes
100000 habitants ou presque à être
confronté au quotidien à ces nuisan
sonores vous êtes installé depuis quand
sur ce secteur à proximité de
l'aérodrome alors moi j'y suis depuis 5
ans lorsque vous êtes arrivé vous étiez
au courant vous l'avez découvert ça
s'est aggravé ces dernières années alors
je l'ai découvert et effectivement ça
s'est considérablement aggravé donc il
faut savoir globalement que l'aérodrome
de saint-tir l'école engendre soit 70000
à 90000 mouvements par an mais réparti
bien évidemment de la saison d'été
printemps été donc de avril à octobre et
bah cela engendre 600 mouvements à peu
près par par jour donc vous imaginez
qu'un jour dimanche ensoleillé vous ne
pouvez absolument pas profiter de votre
jardin étant donné que vous avez un
avion de tourisme toutes les 2 à 3
minutes au-dessus de vos têtes ou juste
à proximité donc avec un vacarme
infernal donc c'est intolérable et la la
situation peut pas rester telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui votre demande vos
demandes avec ces quatre associations
c'est la fermeture de l'aérodrome alors
avant de parler avant justement avant de
parler de de d'avenir de l'aérodrome
nous souhaitons vraiment mettre en place
deux actions donc c'est ce que nous
demandons effectivement aux autorités
compétentes à savoir déjà l'interdiction
euh de voler donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire instaurer des plages de de
silence pour les tours de piste et les
vols locaux qui représentent quand même
90 % bah du trafic aérien de sinsir
l'école les dimanches et les samedis
donc de avril à octobre à compter de
midi est-ce que vous avez échangé déjà
avec les les propriétaires de
l'aérodrome avec les utilisateurs aussi
de ces hélicoptères de ses avions alors
il faut savoir que suivant les quatre
associations que nous représentons il y
en a qui existent depuis déjà plus d'une
dizaine d'années qu'effectivement il y a
des des réunions qui sont faites de
temps à autre que l'on appelle des
comités de suivi on a rencontré
également le regroupement des usagers de
de sinsir l'école avec son responsable
monsieur souris et en fait il s'en suit
des discussions des réunions mais sans
décision Formell et définitive donc en
fait on narrive pas à un
entendement a eu aucune amélioration
est-ce que ils ont quand même modifié
leurs appareils peut-être aussi pour que
ça fasse moins de bruit alors alors
effectivement il y a eu justement depuis
depuis une dizaine d'années la mise en
place de silencieux sur sur des avions
de tourisme en fait on ne constate
aucune amélioration donc parce que trop
proche des
habitations en parallèle de ça il y a
une charte de l'environnement qui a été
mise en place aussi pour pour les
pilotes mais clairement nous ne
constatons aucune amélioration donc
c'est pour ça que nous voulons agir et
demandons aux autorités de de nous aider
donc en plus de la mise en place de Plag
de silence nous souhaitons également que
la DGAC donc la Direction générale de
l'aviation civile avec qui nous sommes
en contact régulièrement travaille
également sur la modification de
trajectoire étant donné que dans cette
zone enclavée c'est impossible d'être
hors survol d'habitation et cette
modification de trajectoire nous
imaginons qu'elle pourrait être
au-dessus de la plaine de Versailles
parce qu'il n'y a aucune habitation donc
il faudrait effectivement revoir le le
PLA font le plafond des vols aujourd'hui
la DGAC refuse pour des raisons de
sécurité mais à notre sens avec
l'urbanisation qui croit de plus en plus
parce qu'il y a des demandes de logement
qui sont faites de partout vous imaginez
bien la situation peut pas rester tel
quel avec les trajectoires qui sont
aujourd'hui mises en place sur la
question de la mise en place de ces
plages de silence le weekend par exemple
pour la direction de l'aérodrome c'est
un sensé il y aurait encore plus de
nuisance le reste de la journée alors il
faut savoir qu'on a des nuisances toute
la journée quand je vous dis
effectivement que c'est un avion toutes
les de à 3 minutes toute la journée vous
préférez éviter avoir des plages de
silence que ce soit pire le reste de la
semaine alors justement si la semaine
était comme le weekend ce serait parfait
c'est ce que je vous disais c'est en
fait t tous les vols sont faits le
samedi et dimanche donc c'est
insupportable nous on ne peut absolument
pas se reposer c'est on est comme tout
le monde on travaille la semaine on a
des jardin c'est aussi pour en profiter
le weekend outre l'aspect de nuisance
sonore il y a vraiment une notion aussi
de danger parce que ils survolent nos
habitations ils se croisent sur des
trajectoires qui sont très étroites
entre 200 et 300 m c'est rien pour pour
pour des avions de tourisme et
finalement outre je vous dis cette
fréquence il y a des habitants qui ont
peur de mettre leurs enfants dans les
jardins vous avez certainement entendu
encore à monté Limar il y a une semaine
voilà un avion qui s'est écrasé faisant
deux morts on va pas attendre qu'un
avion s'écrase sur une maison avec des
enfants d justement vous avez des liens
avec les autres collectifs est-ce que en
lesen qu'il on obir alors exactement
vous avez raison en fait nous constatons
aussi que sur le l'aérodrome de
saint-sire l'école qui est donc le plus
enclavé le plus
urbanisé nous nous constatons vraiment
une discrimination et une injustice en
tant qu'habitant des Yvelines par
rapport à d'autres aérodromes qui qui
sont déjà présents comme toussu le noble
et chavenet qui eux ont des plages de
silence justement les
donc donc voilà donc c'est c'est
vraiment pour ça que nous demandons cela
aussi parce que finalement bah ces
plages de silence ça aide au moins avoir
une certaine tranquillité pour les
habitants à un certain moment de la
journée donc est-ce que la municipalité
vous soutient vous parliez de ces autres
communes mais sur saint-ci tout à fait
donc en fait nous aurons la chance
samedi matin d'avoir au moins h élus de
de bah soit des mes donc
entre plaisir Villepreux bois d'Arc
saint école donc là les maères seront
présents avec nous ce samedi matin et
derrière donc on aura aussi le soutien
de de représentants d'élus à travers les
clés sousbois Bahi fontené fleu
également noisil les rois nous avons
aussi deux conseillers généraux des
Yvelines qui seront présents samedi
matin donc heureusement les élus nous
soutiennent et ils veulent vraiment
qu'on arrive à instaurer ces plages de
silence donc c'est une forte
mobilisation ça commencera à partir de
de 9h vous attendez combien de personnes
ex nous aimerions être au minimum 300
personne donc voilà et notre but c'est
effectivement de de de prévenir les
pilotes de prévenir les autorités sur le
respect sur la tranquillité sur les
dangers que représentent leur vol parce
qu'aujourd'hui ils volent vraiment en
toute impunité et donc c'est ça que nous
souhaitons nous souhaitons décrire avec
eux donc c'est une mobilisation
pacifiste ce sera calme normalement tout
devrait bien se passer est-ce que vous
avez prévu de rencontrer la direction de
l'aérodrome est-ce que vous allez leur
remettre une pétition à l'issue de cette
mobilisation nous on leur remettre des
lettres avec les les actions que l'on
que l'on demande donc action immédiate
avec la plage de silence action à
travailler également pour un changement
de trajectoire donc bien évidemment ils
seront au courant de de nos actions et
donc nous espérons qu'ils réagiront très
vivement et très rapidement sinon nous
continuerons nos actions j'ai une
dernière question à vous poser pour
revenir à votre témoignage et au
difficultés que vous rencontrez est-ce
que vous avez déjà pensé à déménager
aussi pour le moment non je suis très
bien chez chez moi ce serait quand même
dommage d'être obligé de déménager parce
que les les pilotes ne respectent pas un
leur trajectoire et
deux les les les nuisances que l'on a
derrière donc on pense qu'on peut
vraiment trouver des solutions pour que
vous puissiez cohabiter voilà on aime on
aimerait vraiment cohabiter donc le
déménagement n'est pas du tout à l'ordre
du jour et en même temps c'est vraiment
j'insiste l'urbanisation est croissante
donc tout le monde de il y a beaucoup de
réalisation immobilière effectivement de
nouveaux habitants qui vont arriver le
problème va cont déménager pour aller où
voilà merci Muriel guimin d'être venu en
plateau présidente de l'association
contre les nuisances sonores à noisil le
roi et bi et de l'animation donc à
l'aérodrome de saint-ciier l'école
samedi matin DESS 9h avec trois autres
associations de Riverin vous appelez à
manifester merci le centre d'information
Europe Direct dans les Yvelines
partenairire de TVfil depuis la semaine
dernière à travers la séquence l'Europe
et vous à la veille du scrutin nous vous
expliquons le rôle de l'Union dans notre
quotidien ce soir le poids de l'Europe
dans le développement des régions
ces fonds servent tout simplement à
lutter contre ce qu'on appelle la
discrimination territoriale en fait ces
fonds servent
à de manière barbare c'est le
développement économique sociale et
territoriale d'une zone donc
c'est-à-dire que ça sert en fait à
éviter ce qu'on appelle par exemple les
déserts hospitaliers donc ces fonds
interviennent de manière très pratique
soit en finançant la construction
d'infrastructure publique soit en
finançant la rénovation de bâtiments
donc notamment dans le cadre des des a
hospitaliers les fedires vont intervenir
en finançant des hôpitaux par exemple
quand il y a un chantier qui bénéficie
de fond fedire c'est tout simplement il
y a un grand panneau il y a un grand
panneau qui indique soutenu par la
Commission européenne financement fére
donc il suffit qu'on se balade un peu en
France et donc ces panneaux sont très
visibles ça peut être économie culture
ça peut être surtout aussi environnement
là on a un autre fond qui intervient qui
s'appelle le féader et alors par exemple
ça peut un exempleès très concret ça
c'était un village en Pologne qui en
fait était soumis à des des bourrasques
qui allaient généralement à plus de 100
km/h il y avait une zone qui avait été
complètement polluée via une VI a une
centrale chimique en fait tout
simplement via l'action du FEDER et du
fader ils ont dépollué la zone il et ils
ont dépollué la zone et ils ont aussi
ils l'ont reforesté c'est un
investissement sur le long terme on on
ne vise pas on ne vise pas je veux dire
du quelque chose qui va donner la
croissance économique tout de suite et
c'est vraiment pour lutter contre les
clivages régionaux pour désenclaver les
régions qui sont défavorisées donc c'est
un travail qui se fait sur le long terme
ça vise pas particulièrement en fait
l'île-de-fance parce que tout simplement
l'île-de-fance est une zone qui est
suffisamment développée mais par exemple
c'est tout ce qui est des les régions
qui en fait soit ont une géographie qui
est particulièrement défavorable ou soit
par exemple une bon une région par
exemple comme la champagnearden là
effectivement
il en fait des régions qui des régions
qui sont dans la nécessité qui ont
besoin qui se trouvent en fait dans des
situations locales ont effectivement
besoin de fonds Feder et là le FEDER va
davantage intervenir l'Île-de-France ça
fait partie ce qu'on appelle dans la
alors dans la dans la classification
classification européenne on appelle ce
qu'on appelle les nuts donc
l'Île-deFrance on est en 2 ou en 3
c'est-à-dire les zones qui sont bien
développées économiquement où il y a pas
besoin d'intervenir en la
matière sport avec un événement
d'envergure au Vélodrome de 5qu ans en
Yveline la coupe de l'Américaine du
cyclisme nous en parlions déjà hier
voici à présent le résumé de cette
compétition bin où il faut bien sûr
maîtriser la vitesse mais aussi le
passage de relais et là c'est plus
délicat Anthony Jonathan villman c'est
peut-être le moment le plus
spectaculaire de la course à
l'américaine par équipe de de les
concurrents se relaient en plein milieu
du peloton au cuissard ou à la volée de
main à main la course à l'américaine est
une épreuve de point mais aussi de
distance le but est de prendre des tours
à l'adversaire les vainqueurs sont
également partagés par les points acquis
lors des sprints intermédiaires un
règlement par fois complexe qui peine à
attirer le public en tribune c'est vrai
qu'elle est complexe par elle-même et
que les gens vont vont davantage vers le
sprint la poursuite ou même l'adition de
Po qui est la cousine de l'Américaine
mais c'est vrai que l'Américaine a du
mal à rentrer dans le public au sein de
ce peloton d'une quarantaine d'unités
Thomas Boudda et Bryan kocar sont
évidemment les grands favoris du jour le
champion du monde de l'Omnium 2014 sort
d'un stage avec l'équipe de France sur
piste et veut évidemment décrocher cette
Coupe de France c'est encore plus
stratégique parce que ça se fait
vraiment à rien parce qu'on est souvent
plein d'équipes au même niveau et ça se
joue à une attaque à un demi-tour près
si on la place bien comme il faut Thomas
bouda et Bry cocard vont attaquer au
moment idéal après 30 passages sur la
ligne l'équipe des Pays de la Loire
reprend un tour au Ploton et s'assure la
victoire finale au fil des kilomètres
les deux prodiges s'imposent finalement
avec tro tours d'avance de quoi faire
respectiv le plein de confiance avant
les Championnats d'Europe sur piste et
le Tour de
France santé avec les 70 ans des Blouses
Roses les les Blouses Roses 4300
bénévoles répartis dans toute la France
qui Contin continu de redonner le
sourire au malades à travers différents
loisirs organisés au sein des
établissements pour fêter cet
anniversaire le comité versaillais s'est
réuni hier mercredi dans le hall de
l'hôpital m au chînet l'occasion de se
faire connaître davantage et pourquoi
pas de recruter de nouveaux bénévoles
car 70 ans après l' a toujours autant de
succès auprès des malades on apporte que
du bien-être on fait oublier les murs de
l'hôpital et on a notre slogan sourier
c'est gagner en fait quand on a eu un
sourire on a gagné la partie et c'est
notre récompense quand on vient souvent
comme nous ils sont reconnus donc c'est
ah tiens tu reviens me voir il y a des
petites blagues sur qu'est-ce que tu as
fait depuis le mois dernier enfin bon
voilà il y a un petit lien quand même
qui se crée et c'est très sympa quoi
propos recueil par yolen Torz diine nous
terminons ce journal avec l'étape
yvelinoise du Paris fermier c'est un
salon qu'organise eux-mêmes les
producteurs une dizaine de fois dans
l'année à travers la France le weekend
dernier c'était à Rambouillet et parmi
les 120 exposants certains sont
d'anciens citadins à la recherche d'un
autre mode de vie Catherine
zulato faire écter si voulez un côe de
bruit Jacques charmetan a travaillé
pendant 10 ans dans l'agroalimentaire à
près de 40 ans en 1993 il décide de
changer de vie et de se lancer avec son
épouse Caroline comme vigneron dans le
beaujolet avec du recul c'était un peu
de la folie mais mais on est parti
là-dessus il a dû se former aux méthodes
de l'onologie et son rêve est devenu
réalité mais au prix de beaucoup
d'efforts ce qui a étéit dur au départ
c'était de pouvoir s'installer dans un
vignoble où il y avait pas encore la
crise comme aujourd'hui donc il y avait
pas de place pour les étrangers donc ça
c'était pas évident de trouver du
foncier pour s'installer une maison et
cetera fauted
démarrer voilà c'est c'est un métier B
c'est un métier multiples facettes assez
compliqué assez exigeant et voilà où on
a qu'une expérience par an au niveau du
vin puisqueon fait le vin qu'une fois
par an on était porté par une espèce
d'inconscience enfin un rêve et cetera
ce qui fait on déploie une énergie
extraordinaire quo que pour arriver à
nos fins quoi ce qui a aujourd'hui
changé dans la vie de Caroline et
Jacques c'est leur quotidien la nature
est exigeante mais elle leur rend bien
bah de la qualité puis du Bio pas trop
cher pas trop cher honnête come pris
honnêteté c'est aussi le qualificatif
que l'on pourrait attribuer au travail
de Laurent sagur il y a 20 ans cette
préparatrice en pharmacie quitte
l'Alsace pour le gare et ses champs
d'Amand en friche mon mari a repris des
des champs qui étaient à l'abandon on a
recommencé à y travailler et puis petit
à petit B voilà on est là aujourd'hui
donc on transforme déjà on produit on
transforme et on vend directement
souvent on oublie les années un petit
peu difficiles et on au départ on on a
commencé à transformer dans notre
cuisine on avait deux trois produits
dans notre cuisine et puis tout d'un
coup on s'est retrouvé avec voilà une
grande gamme à labo et donc on s'est dit
qu'en 20 ans on a quand même fait pas
mal de de chemins aujourd'hui ça
commence à aller doucement on a eu le
premier prix du mérite agricole en
développement durable donc c'est un prix
national qu'on a eu en janvier donc ça
c'est là qu'on se rend vraiment compte
qu'on a fait quelque chose voilà
d'intéressant le plus compliqué qu' de
Laurent c'est de ne pas connaître les
bonnes filières et les bonnes méthodes
de vente mais l'amand française
rencontre maintenant son succès un
succès construit aussi avec
l'association Paris fermier un
groupement de producteurs fermiers qu'il
y a 22 ans a fait le choix d'aller à la
rencontre des consommateurs c'est amener
les produits du seroir au citadin et
écouter ce que les citadins ont à dire
sur les produits du terroir et sur la
campagne en général les les citadins
volulent certaines choses veulent
certains produits ils ont raison et nous
on leur amène de l'authenticité et c'est
ce qu' cherche et cela fonctionne en 8
ans le salon annuel de Rambouillet est
pass de 3000 à 18000
visiteurs prochain journal même heure ce
vendredi je recevrai Guillaume Porcheron
chargé de mission Développement Durable
à véis ville à coubla une ville engagée
dans la biomimétique c'est une cité qui
se base sur le rythme de l'écosystème la
ville qui se calque sur la nature les
détails demain très bonne
soirée